HAS NOW GONE INTO INTENSIVE
CARE.
SO WE WILL FOLLOW THAT QUITE
CLOSELY FROM LONDON.
MEANTIME COME ON BOARD THAT NAVY
SHIP, THE NAVY SECRETARY YOU
FILE THE ONBOARD THE
USS ROOSEVELT.
APPARENTLY DESCRIBED HIM AS
BEING TOO STUPID OR NAIVE FOR
THE JOB.
HE MADE THE COMMENTS OVER THE
SHIP’S P.A. SYSTEM, AND
JENNIFER GRIFFIN HAS LEAD STORY
NOW FROM THE PENTAGON.
WHAT HAPPENED JENNIFER?
>> WELL, BILL, THE ACTING NAVY
SECRETARY THOMAS MODLY FLEW OUT
TO QUAN WITHOUT A PUBLIC AFFAIRS
TEAM AND DELIVERED A BLISTERING,
PROFANITY LADEN SPEECH
CHASTISING THE SAILORS ON
BOARD THE USS ROOSEVELT AND
MOCKING CAPTAIN BRETT CROZIER’S
DECISION TO PUT IN WRITING MY HE
THOUGHT MOST OF THE SAILORS ON
BOARD THE AIRCRAFT CARRIER
NEEDED TO BE REMOVED FROM THE
SHIP IN GUAM AS A NUMBER OF
COVID CASES ON BOARD EXPLODED.
>> HE DIDN’T THINK THAT
INFORMATION WAS GOING TO GET OUT
INTO THE PUBLIC.
IN THIS INFORMATION AGE THAT WE
LIVE IN, HE WAS EITHER TOO NAIVE
OR TOO STUPID.
>> AS THOMAS MODLY SPOKE OVER
THE SHIP’S INTERCOM SYSTEM, MANY
OF THE SAME SAILORS WHO CHEERED
FOR THEIR CAPTAIN AS HE LEFT THE
SHIP AFTER THE ACTING NAVY
SECRETARY FIRED HIM FOR IGNORING
THE CHAIN OF COMMAND EXPRESSED
STUNNED DISBELIEF WHEN THOMAS
MODLY DESCRIBES THE CAPTAIN’S
ACTIONS AS A BETRAYAL OF THEM IN
THE NAVY.
BRETT CROZIER HIMSELF HAS SINCE
TESTED POSITIVE FOR COVID-19.
>> NOT TO COMPLAIN.
EVERYONE IS SCARED ABOUT THIS
THING.
BUT I WILL TELL YOU SOMETHING,
IF THE SHIP WAS IN COMBAT AND
THEY WERE HYPERSONIC MISSILES
COMING AT IT, YOU WOULD BE
PRETTY [BLEEP]ING SCARED TOO.
BUT YOU DO YOUR JOB.
THAT’S IT I EXPECT YOU TO DO,
THAT’S WHAT I SPECKED EVERYONE
ON THE SHIP TO DO, TO DO YOUR
JOB.
>> THOMAS MODLY ISSUED A
STATEMENT MOMENTS AGO EXPLAINING
WHY HE WAS PROFANITY EXPRESSING
THAT IS HOW SAILORS TALK.
173 SAILORS ON THE SHIP HAVE
TESTED POSITIVE.
NEARLY 2,000 HAVE BEEN REMOVED
FROM THE SHIP.
MANY WONDER WHETHER THE ACTING
SECRETARY WILL ALSO FIRE THE
NAVY LEADERS WHO TOOK THE
DECISION TO MAKE A FIVE-DAY PORT
CALL IN TO VIETNAM IN MARCH.
THAT DECISION WAS NOT MADE BY